hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of his treatise on the
basis of morality arthur schopenhauer
is going to have a lengthy discussion of
justice and thereby of injustice and
their relation to compassion but he's
also going to go into some important
clarificatory discussions as well and
one of these has to do with the nature
of wrongs and rights in relation to
justice and injustice
and this occurs fairly early on in the
chapter number 17 on the virtue of
justice
he tells us that injustice or wrong
always consists in injuring
another in doing some
harm to them right so
which is injustice always involves
harming another another getting
harmed and he goes on and says
the concept of
wrong or literally unright un-wrecked
right
is a positive one it's one that we are
presented with and can grasp in a
positive manner we see
injustice we see wrong being committed
we experience it very often ourselves
and very interestingly he says that it
precedes the concept of right it is
antecedent to it so logically
the concept of wrong is prior
to that of right by
contrast he tells us
the concept of right is negative
and this is a very important position
that he's taking schopenhauer is in
effect telling us
that that rights are defined by
not being wrong rather than in a
positive
way themselves so he tells us that right
denotes merely those actions that can be
done
without injuries to others that is
without wrong
being done and so there's
really two important formulations going
on right there right
there's one that's about potential
actions that can be done
without injury to others i mean
we could probably
come up with some sort of crazy
imagined example for any innocent
activity and how it could involve harm
to others i'm walking down the street
just whistling
and i you know traumatize somebody who
associates that whistling with something
that happened to them in their past and
they're triggered
schopenhauer is not worried about things
like that he's worried about you know
what
is likely to produce harm and then he
says
without wrong being done right so not
doing wrong
involves uh
the right
and he says it's easy to see that two
such actions
also belong all those whose soul object
and that's very important whose sole
object
is to ward off an attempted
wrong and he says no participation in
the interests of another
no sympathy for him
can require me
to let myself be injured by him that is
to say to
suffer wrong so i i have a
right to you could say establish and and
maintain
limits to say no i
i'm happy to help you out but i'm not
going to
be forced
into
helping you out or preventing harm to
you or or things like that and he'll
he'll talk about this a little bit more
later on when he brings up a
what he calls a law of moral
repercussion
he tells us that
the
pure understanding
has ready to hand the principle causa
cause i asked causa effectus right the
cause of a cause is also the cause of
its effect which here says that the
other man
not i is the cause of whatever i must do
to ward off the injury he intends to do
me and so i can resist all encroachments
on his part without doing him any wrong
so somebody wants to
assault me
i have the right to use force or as he's
going to say a little bit later on if i
have the right to use force i also have
the right to lie to him a robber who
says what do you got in your wallet i
can say
uh it's empty you know i can also resist
them with force i have the right to do
that but in general the concept of a
right is going to be negative right or
include actions where we're again
negating a wrong and this leads us to
what we can call the
negative nature of
justice
he says that um the concept of right is
negative in contrast to that of wrong
which is positive uh we see this in all
sorts of illustrations then he says
contrary to appearance the negative
nature of justice is established even in
the trite definition
give to each his own and he observes
very rightly
that gives to each their own
can't be something that you do in a
completely negative way if if you've
already got people
getting what is their own their property
their reputation their honor their
freedom their own bodies and things like
that just keep your hands
off of
theirs he says if a man has his own
there's no need to give it to him and so
the meaning of give to everybody their
own is really take from no one what is
his own and he says this demand of
justice is merely
negative and can be summed up with
the harm or injure
no one
now because it is negative according to
schopenhauer
it can be enforced you can you can tell
people hands off and if you're going to
do something positive that violates that
a unright or a wrong
a instance of injustice well then it's
easy to see and to identify and thereby
to enforce to
punish
what is the way in which this happens
here he goes into a bit of a discussion
about the state right the we could call
this the political
governance but
we might also think about this in many
other ways can this be enforced within
say the family can it be enforced within
neighborhoods by a social sanction can
this be enforced within
you know what schopenhauer would view as
voluntary associations or institutions
like academics or the corporate world
probably schopenhauer would be willing
to go along with that but here he says
the compulsory institution is the state
whose sole purpose is to protect
individuals from one another and the
whole from external foes and what we see
here is schopenhauer going into
a bit of a digression or rant or a side
about you know states these days he's
sort of like an old guy who's
complaining about kids these days but
his point is that states are
overreaching
in trying to make rights
and the protection of rights something
positive rather than something
enforcing a
negative he says that
a few german fellow fosters of this
mercenary age would like to distort the
state into an institution for spreading
morality right spreading morality by
saying you have to behave in moral ways
rather than you
have to not behave in immoral ways you
see the difference between the two of
those one is positive one is negative
and uh edifying instruction right
edifying instruction up building
instruction that's going to make us into
better people and then he says
here lurks in the background the
jesuitical purpose of doing away with
personal freedom and individual
development in order to make men into
mere wheels of a chinese machine of
state and religion and then he you know
brings up you know inquisitions otto's
defeat and religious wars
being rather alarmist in that manner but
it's good to keep in mind that
schopenhauer is closer to those things
in in time than we are
and he sees that um we see that
with the exception of north america he
says the state undertakes even the
provision for the metaphysical needs of
its members governments appear to have
chosen as their principle
this aphorism of uh quinteus courteous
nothing rules the masses so effectively
a superstition as a rule they're
unbridled cruel fickle and irresolute so
as soon as they're caught by some
delusion of religion they prefer to obey
their priests rather than their leaders
and schopenhauer is saying we we should
put that aside that's not the way states
should be behaving if the goal
is to
punish offenders who violate the rights
of others those rights being conceived
in a negative
rather than positive
way
it comes back to
talking about the the origin of this
understanding and he tells us
that once again the concepts of right
and wrong are you know
positive and negative and then he adds
that they're independent of
an ah priority to legislation why is he
making this point
really two reasons one is to
suggest that against those who are what
we call legal positivists or
have a you know
view on um
we could say the relation between
legality and morality and political
authority that says might makes right
schopenhauer wants to reject that he
also wants to say that prior to and
therefore
guiding
legislation
is some sort of as he's going to call it
purely ethical or
natural rights
so
what is the basis for this he tells us
that um
here we go it involves a union
of empir the empirical concept of
wrongdoing what does that mean so
we all get to
witness wrongdoing sometimes we do it
ourselves sometimes we suffer it we're
all pretty familiar with injury harm
humiliation pick whatever you want and
we have a
conception of right as being opposite of
that as you know what doesn't harm other
people
and what wards off harm so we've got an
empirical concept on the one hand
something drawn from experience
and a rule of the pure understanding he
says so we've got the empirical and the
we could call it whatever we want
conceptual the the intellectual going on
at the same time
and coming together so he tells us that
this gives rise to the fundamental
concepts of wrong and right which
everybody
grasps ah
before
having any particular experience and
applies at once the instance of
experience and then he says
some people might say that this isn't
really the case and they might point at
what he calls the savages people who are
considered to be more primitive so you
know at the time that he's writing we
might think about peoples of africa
or
indigenous peoples in the americas and
schopenhauer says
an empiricist who claims this just isn't
a good empiricist just watch what
happens when you deal with these people
that you're calling
primitives or savages he says this is
obvious and they're bartering in other
transactions with the crews of european
ships they're bold and full of
confidence when right is on their side
when they're when they know in this a
priori way
that they're doing what's within their
rights they're not harming anybody
they're anxious and uneasy when it is
not
in disputes they approve of a just
settlement an unjust method drives them
to war so schopenhauer is saying listen
everybody
across the world in every culture at
every time
is going to be able to get this on some
fundamental level you don't actually
need some sort of teaching
to
get this started it might be helpful for
clarifying things but this is prior to
any sort of legislation
or education and then he talks about
jurisprudence jurisprudence the doctrine
of right he tells us is a branch of
morals which determines those actions
we are not allowed to commit unless we
intend to injure others that is to do
wrong and he tells us morality has in
view here the active part the
not doing wrong
us as agents jurisprudence says
you will not do this
you know kill your neighbor for example
or rob them
because you are thereby doing wrong to
them right and legislation he says takes
this chapter of morality in order to use
it with regard to the
passive side
to consider
the same actions which no one need
endure since no wrong should befall him
and he says against these actions the
state constructs the bold work of the
laws as positive right its intention
for the state is that no one shall
suffer wrong legislation is about that
nobody should suffer wrong nobody should
be
harmed nobody should have their rights
infringed upon right
and then he says where is the intention
of moral jurisprudence is that nobody
should do wrong so we've got
suffering on one side
being affected and then we've got doing
and the wrong is in between and we've
got jurisprudence and legislation so
you can see here that schopenhauer is
engaged in a process of
clarifying for us the readers just what
wrong
and right really mean in the scope of
his theory
you